i have a great example for you today of
techniques to counter propaganda many
times uh people will ask
how is it best to react
when someone asserts this or says that
and you know that their reason for
bringing it up is a bad faith reason or
the premise is wrong or whatever the
case may be so we're going to talk about
this today using an example from fox
news reporter peter ducey who's always
trying to
make himself look i guess big and strong
and like a real reporter and like a guy
who asks important questions and the
technique here is ask for examples when
you are given a premise
and you know
that the premise is shaky or it's being
used to make a point that doesn't
actually follow the first thing is make
them defend the premise don't just
accept it and uh fox's peter ducey
asked a white house press secretary jen
saki about the don't say gay bill from
florida and the question he asked was
does the white house support
teaching kids younger than kindergarten
sex education or gender education you
know whatever the case may be and
jensaki smartly says
do you even have examples of when that's
being done because if you don't you're
really just saying
will biden denounce something that's not
even going on and that's what we would
define as a pointless question to answer
so let's look at the clip and then we're
going to talk about it so if you guys
oppose this law that
bans classroom instruction about
sexual orientation and gender identity
in k-3 does white house support that
kind of classroom instruction before
kindergarten do you have examples of
schools in uh florida that are teaching
kindergarteners about sex education i'm
just asking for the president i think
that's a i think that's a relevant
question because i think this is a
politically charged
harsh law that is putting
parents and lgbtq plus kids in a very
difficult
a heartbreaking circumstance and so i
actually think that's a pretty relevant
question so this is a really good
technique uh and i'm going to talk about
it a little more in a second so first of
all understand that what steve ducey uh
peter ducey brings up
it's it's just not happening it's not
happening um
first of all when we talk about sexual
orientation instruction the don't say
gay bill is about in k through 3
and ducey goes further by saying before
k through three so you're talking about
daycare you're talking about infants
being given sex education or whatever i
looked for a while and i found no i
don't i didn't even find any allegations
that it was happening now had i found
allegations i would have tried to find
proof i haven't even found allegations
that kids younger than kindergarten are
being taught this type of material
and it's just uh there's just no
evidence that it's going on
so
gensake is smart here and
the
real reasons to oppose the bill of
course are that it's outrageously
homophobic in its underpinnings it's
absurdly transphobic
it's obviously a double standard because
when it says you can't talk about gender
you can't talk about romantic
relationships all these different things
if it were applied
fairly
and consistently
a heterosexual teacher shouldn't even
really be allowed to talk about her
husband or his wife if it is a man but
of course the point is not actually to
apply it equally do you think anyone is
going i mean maybe to try to make a
political point it'll happen but do you
think that if the parents of a first
grader here
that mrs smith talked about her husband
mr smith they're going to show up and
say they're violating the the bill
they're violating the bill no of course
not because the whole point of it is
fundamentally homophobic and transphobic
uh but the the bad faith piece is
saying
do you favor
the thing that the bill bans or do you
favor this thing
that the bill may be banned but isn't
even actually happening and this is a
common technique that they like to use
this came up when i was interviewed
remember this guy jesse lee peterson a
couple years ago i was out in los
angeles for politicon and jesse lee
peterson invited me to
his studio
for an interview
and he started talking to me about obama
being socialist and making everything
socialist and i took the exact same
approach here that jen saki took which
is to say
what socialist things did obama do or
even try to do and it imploded
i would say it imploded in humiliating
fashion for jesse i don't know that he's
capable of actually feeling humiliated
so it should have but here's a reminder
of how that all went down but so here
let me ask you about this
i'm not a socialist myself i'm a social
just to be clear i'm i don't i'm not
advocating for social media
i don't know that many actual socialists
like who would
who where's the big desire for the us to
become socialists if you look at the
democratic party there's almost no
socialists in the democratic socialist
communist party now
that's one socialist idea from the
democratic party um uh socialized
healthcare no that's a social social
democracy program no
denmark socialist and if you notice that
barack obama
the father messiah you know he's the
father messiah right
i don't know anything about that well
big mama michelle
uh he tried to turn america into a
socialist society what's one example of
a socialist policy that he had uh
socialized healthcare he didn't do that
he did for-profit obamacare taking care
of everybody how so by getting rid of
jobs many people emotionally took care
of people about getting into full-time
jobs and they had to work two part-time
jobs in order to survive so you don't
even understand the talking points the
rest stopped working and just went and
depended on and relied on the government
free obama phones
that's socialism
you're so how can you so
i want to ask a real question
i'm asking you a real question obama
phones are not socialism
so it's a good technique uh ducey is a
clown
he's unable to provide even a single
example because there are none no one is
sitting no one's sitting in pre-k
teaching sex education or about
transgender people or whatever
it's just not happening and once again
this is one of those things where
they're doing it to
judge katanji brown jackson as well
there is of course no evidence that
judge jackson
likes pedophilia
supports it defends it
but they are taking out of however many
sentences she's given
some cases where the sentence fell short
of the maximum or of what the
prosecution wanted and using that as
evidence that she must be in favor of
this thing she just must be right i mean
she must she must defend the pedophiles
or the sex uh child sexual predators or
whoever the case may be
it's non-existent
understand the technique use the
technique
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
15 off all products and free shipping go
to vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below